is there actually any evidence that the
Earth is rapidly warming I mean sure
NASA produces these data sets that show
the atmosphere is warming at an
unprecedented rate but can you really
trust NASA can you really trust the
dozens of independent research groups
around the world that have also shown
the temperature of the atmosphere is
increasing all their data sets showing a
huge buildup of heat in the oceans okay
apart from the data from the atmosphere
in the ocean is there really any
evidence well there is the data set
combining multiple ice cores from across
Greenland to produce a temperature graph
that shows the temperature there hasn't
been higher for two thousand years and
the fact that green London Antarctica
together are losing over 420 million
tons of ice to melt every year and the
fact that temperature related
accumulation of metals in marine animals
has been shown to increase in the past
several decades and the fact that bird
migrations now take place over markedly
different routes and at different times
due to change temperatures and more
extreme weather events and the
increasingly early flowering of plant
species such as cherry trees and Kyoto
brought on by high temperatures right so
apart from the Independent atmospheric
Oceanic cryological biological chemical
and migratory evidence is there really
any evidence for climate change